[Music]
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
[Music]
would be clogged
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
[Music]
[Music]
god bless
the united states
look at that look at that
look at that look at that
look at that look at that that
is smarter than you why
pac-man's a loser
alex jones is lying to you that might
come as a shock man
[Music]
jones has fake
[Music]
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship d-banking
arrest tyranny look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser he's a disgrace
he's his christ
and he's a disgrace and he's with his
christ look at that look at that
look at that
look at that look at that
look at that look at that
look at that
moment of the sexual experience would
ask the young lady who's your daddy this
should be remixed if officer akimov is
watching this could be the next remix
masterpiece dude because just wait till
you see what happens here oh officer
officer akimov is here uh that's
beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
oh i'm a christian
[Music]
is the most successful pimp on planet
earth to reverence the word of god to
trust it to preach it to teach it
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of life
[Music]
and loads of money and tons and tons of
lies
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
george bush singer and george bush jr
have been penetrated by at least 100 men
in their anus a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand strong i didn't do it
that's not my problem oh i got down on
my knees
i didn't do it i was tempted
sounds like quite an evening
loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
all right welcome everybody we've got a
big big day for you today
i'll i will explain uh we're going to go
through some of the news we're going to
talk about what's going on with nuclear
power
nuclear power plants hold on you know
what i just sounded like i think i have
it here
wait a second
nuclear equilibration exactly um we're
going
we're going to talk about that we will
be talking about
oil oil prices and then at the top of
the hour i am going to be doing an ama
on the politics discord this is a big
big deal this is a discord that has a
ton of people there's like
forty thousand sixty thousand a million
people on this discord it's one of the
biggest politics discords i'm gonna be
doing an ama there
at the top of the hour if you want to
participate i guess you go to
discord.ggslash
politics
discord dot gg slash politics so that
that'll be a little later and i thought
i would stream myself doing the ama
for
content and that um sort of thing so
that'll be at the top of the hour
welcome everybody let's start with
what's going on with these nuclear
plants uh cnn reporting russian takeover
of zaparizia
nuclear plant triggers new exodus of
women and children
as the evacuation train rolled slowly
into the main railroad station in the
southeastern city in ukraine of
zaparizia on saturday panic began to
rise to claim a few of the limited
spaces aboard people waiting for hours
in freezing temperatures people trying
to get the hell out and it is horrifying
what is going on there are now
multiple
nuclear power stations taken over by
russia and this is quickly becoming one
of the biggest
refugee crises
humanitarian crises i mean you look
around the world and you look at the big
uh what's the plural of exodus is it
exide
i guess i don't really know
um
in any case you look at the big ones and
you've got afghanistan
you've got
venezuela
but it's very quickly becoming the
ukrainian exodus
one of the
exodus is plural sort of like a deer and
five deer
two exodus that doesn't sound right i
don't know um it's absolutely horrifying
horrifying horrifying what is going on
and i mean some of the images i can't i
don't even want to show
because it will be
potentially problematic from the
standpoint of terms and conditions and
uh everything but
that is going on now with multiple
nuclear power stations taken over by
russia so that's one thing that's going
on
on the other hand we now are seeing in
the last couple hours
not only the united sheish
but also the uk saying that they will be
banning russian oil imports and this
will
increase the price of gas
this will increase the price of gas
but uh we in the u.s we get about eight
percent of our oil from russia now you
might say sir wait a second trump said
we were energy independent and then we
weren't really there here's the deal
folks okay here's the deal wait do i
have my thing not a joke right
um for several years now under trump and
biden the u.s has produced as much oil
as the u.s has used but
that doesn't mean we only use our own
oil we produce as much as we use but
some of it we export and then we also
import from russia
so
don't get confused about that whole
thing
but
the u.s will ban russian oil
the uk will ban russian oil and as you
can see if we look at
crude oil i don't know if this is light
sweet crude or skim or what it is but in
any case crude oil
up four percent today and as you can see
up very strongly over the last month or
so up about 37 38
from roughly 92 ish now up to 124 so gas
will get more expensive
it is not joe biden's fault in the sense
that globally gas prices are up
i think i've now said
uh
five times i've explained this there are
basically
uh three things four things presidents
can do
to impact the price of oil and gas
number one
we can invade a country that produces
oil and this tends to cause oil prices
to spike and gas prices to spike that's
number one
number two
the president can
lobby for gas taxes to go up or to go
down now you might imagine
if you raise gas taxes
gas goes up
if you lower gas taxes
any can anybody guess gas goes down okay
um number three
a u.s president can uh dip into the
strategic petroleum reserve
uh that is not by the way nuclear
nuclear proliferation no we're talking
about oil
strategic petroleum reserve and on a
short-term basis that can very modestly
bring down the price of gas
about 18 cents generally speaking as
what's mentioned um and number four
uh a president can um
uh engage in
uh sanctions so to speak and in this
case it is uh sort of a
eu uk us and so you know you you could
argue
that uh some small i mean we're talking
about eight percent
some small amount western policy
continues to push up the price of crude
but this is global and to blame it on
joe biden is uh
a little bit silly
a little bit silly now i did send out
a pretty powerful tweet earlier and i
encourage you to read it in fact i'll
read it for you right now
which is i 100 understand the economic
crunch that even higher gas prices will
cause
and transitioning off oil takes time
but shouldn't this crisis be prompting
way more discussion of switching to
renewables
i get it we're not going to do it
overnight
but it's been years that we're
humiliatingly
pathetic
on getting off of oil
and this should be like at the top of
mind like imagine if we had been doing
that all along that might have been kind
of a good idea
um where are gas prices now yeah i'll
talk about that in a moment
let me say a few thank yous as people uh
file in respectfully
over on twitch i want to say thanks to
jen here vaderette oceanova family media
tulmu
hentai lover
shoplifting empath
for the twitch prime subscriptions thank
you to all seven of you i also want to
say thanks on my website to winston
bacchus
as well as leonardo diamico
new members eight and nine today folks
let's do a free item coupon code please
don't war whoever is the next member
number 10 will get a free item from my
online store
coffee mug hat hoodie sweatshirt t-shirt
we've got data mail t-shirts we've got
if the ivanka weren't my daughter
t-shirt all the t-shirts free item to
whoever is new member number 10
at
joinpackman.com
we'll send it anywhere in the world sent
one to australia last week you can use
the coupon code please don't war if you
would like you can use the coupon code
obama
if you would like whoever is new member
number 10 that's the next one
you get a free item
which is very very serious if you're
just joining i will be participating in
an ama at the top of the hour on the
politics discord which you can find at
discord.ggslash
politics there's a section called david
pakman ama
you can join that
and i think it's going to be great we're
going to be answering all sorts of
questions at the top of the hour
and i can't wait to see all of you there
okay
let's talk about um
let's talk about gas prices are gas
prices at a record high now
let me ask the audience the following
question
do you understand or should i explain
nominal versus real gas prices is that a
do we understand
or do we need explanation
understand explain
understand explain
one person understands everybody else
says explain okay no okay i'll i'll
explain it so here's the deal
uh if i were to say to you listen
um
if i say to you
i paid 100 bucks for a car in 1970
and i paid 100 bucks for a car in 2020.
did i pay the same amount for those two
cars
no
because of the effect of inflation of
course of course so we are indeed
getting to a point where
nominally
gas prices are higher than ever
but inflation adjusted
we have had higher gas prices in the
past now
i don't deny
that we will almost certainly get to the
most expensive gas prices in history in
real inflation-adjusted terms we are
just not there yet
and when that happens i will tell you
and we will make a big announcement
we'll have some kind of you know
something and we will ban men maybe
we'll do that or maybe i'll just tell
you that that it's happening but yes a
very very vertical element here as you
can see
uh okay what else do we have
oh hold on a second here the free item
goes to
the free item goes to
i need timpani actually someone can send
me a timpani
um
audio for the sound board i really
should be doing a timpani roll
elizabethgood is new member number 10
you've won a free item you can email me
info
davidpakman.com
and i can't tell you how proud i am to
thank an anonymous person who has just
gifted
25
subscriptions on twitch 25 subscriptions
thank you to whoever did that
thank you also to the old tired road for
the twitch sub
and in all seriousness also thanks to
terria borsch who just signed up on my
website
christina hillard
alexander salinas and christopher bailey
new members 37 through 40 on my website
or 40
as joe biden likes to say
over on youtube
natural born keeler says uncharged
pickles for everyone
love your show david
piccolos thank you
and also big thanks to captain smiles22
for gifting five on twitch and b
kimberly has also dropped in a
subscription appreciate everybody i mean
really every everybody's great
um ten minutes from now we are going to
be doing i am going to be doing an ama
on the
politics discord okay now i want to be
really clear about how you participate
in this if you want to participate in
the discord in just a few minutes
go to discord dot gg
slash politics
and go into the section marked
oh wait where is it marked now
it's marked twitch.tv slash david pakman
okay it was called david pakman ama but
all right
twitch.t there's a section and you click
join the ama under my name let me see if
everything's good here
uh
i'm getting spammed relentlessly let me
see if i can it's horrifying okay uh
discord dot gg slash david pakman okay
couple other notes number one
i can't even read this what is it oh
okay this is very cool
i am going to be giving back to the
community
and one thing that we are offering right
now is the opportunity
to receive free okay guys free
free coaching from me on growing your
online content platform now here are the
rules and
20 people have already broken the rules
and it's toxic okay
if you would like to join a curated
group or four or five people to be
coached by me in growing your online
content production platforms
you can apply
at davidpakman.com
coaching now
do you apply by emailing me no
do you email and say i'd like to apply
no
do you email
at all
no you go to davidpakman.com
coaching and you fill out the form okay
you have to already be creating content
this is not we got a couple applicants
that have a channel with no videos or
one video that's six months old no this
is i i can't help you start the point
here is to get existing content creators
we're going to have
zoom
sessions which will be put made public
these will be for everybody to learn
okay
uh you have to already be creating
content somewhere regularly
davidpakman.com
coaching do not email me do not email me
do not email me okay ideally some kind
of news or politics content but we'll
consider anything all right that's
number one number two i do need a little
bit of technical advice if there are
people in the audience who are uh
well-versed in elements of audio
i am rebuilding my mobile production kit
and one of the things i want to do is i
don't want to travel around with this
this is not convenient to travel around
with so my goal is to switch to a teeny
tiny
lavalier microphone but i want good
audio quality and importantly i might be
in rooms that are not treated like this
one so ideally it would be a microphone
that would sound rich
even if the room is kind of crappy
echoey etc if you have a suggestion here
please email info davidpakman.com
with the subject microphone and please
you know make clear
here's a mic that is tiny teeny teeny
tiny
uh but that you will be happy with the
audio because it i just need a small
small kit okay so people who are
well-versed in the audio stuff can do
that and i would very very much
appreciate that
okay
um a couple of clips before we start the
um ama
here is a florida man
blaming
vladimir putin's invasion of ukraine for
um speeding check this out i'm so sorry
sir i need to see your insurance card
please
you got any registration yeah there was
no reason for that at all i would put
people's lives into safety and i just
found out i'm trying to tell you the
truth guy i just found out that putin
has just
said he's going to launch nuclear
thermal war against the world i was
trying to get back to my house finally
what's going on yeah nuclear
proliferation
nuclear energy nuclear facilities
nuclear proliferation yeah so anyway
that guy blaming putin for speeding so
there's that
um
oh we already did that uh oh okay and
this is pretty big news proud boy leader
enrique tario has been arrested this
morning
in his uh in his ruse in his underoos
for conspiracy in connection with the
january sixth riots check this out
there he is
giving the peace sign and wearing
wearing his ruse
so pretty strong arrest taking place
this morning
that's proud boy leader enrique tario
taken into custody
really couldn't happen to a nicer guy
you know
so anyway he was uneventfully taken into
custody uh very very much and uh
quite quite a scene thanks to apparatso
for the twitch prime subscription i
really appreciate that whoa
windows noise out of nowhere
and uh we are getting very very close to
the ama once again if you're just
joining us
i'm about to do an ama
on the politics
discord go to discord dot g g
slash politics
join the david pakman section
let's see what else is going on i'm just
continually getting spammed in a
completely toxic way on discord
uh there we go yeah so that's going to
be starting momentarily discord is up
it's all working i'm streaming it here
yes i'm going to stream the entire thing
live so i hope that i hope that you will
join me thanks also to doobie dooby just
signed up via uh twitch prime which i
also really appreciate that we're also
monitoring a senate hearing on the
russian attack on ukraine joe biden will
be speaking at the bottom of the hour so
there's a lot of things going on but the
ama is going to start momentarily
uh
and will i do another free item at 50.
sure okay i mean i guess um yeah let's
do it if new we're at 48 members okay
this is very simple math if we get to 50
whoever is number 50 gets a free item
from my online store elizabeth won a
free item earlier
if you sign up at joinpacman.com use a
coupon code don't use a coupon code it's
up to you
whoever's number 50 which is two away
gets a free item
turd ferguson is number 49. okay so it's
the next one the next person to sign up
at joinpakman.com
gets a free item
uh we have t-shirts hoodies sweatshirts
you know all sorts of different stuff
um
all right two minutes until the ama
starts let's listen a little bit to
what's going on here
as they confront these
horrific
incidents
in getting documentation and ensuring
that they
get that out to the world and we are
preparing as an international community
to respond to all of that all right and
before the ama starts let's do one
voicemail from
eric from mass
hey david is sarah from math i'm
wondering if you're gonna do an
exclusive on the nine pages of uh side
effects that pfizer released
you know what i mean no
i mean hulk hogan already contacted you
to see what are you gonna do when aids
runs wild on you vaccine and due fades
and yeah vaccine and due states is not
real for the side effects
so
it's going to be a rough road for you to
explain uh
why
you went against people like me and just
continued on and on and on with your
horseshit and getting people hurt and
chilling with yaha [ __ ]
yeah i don't think so um so that's not
going to be happening all right new
member number 50 getting a free item is
alexandiano
email info
davidpakman.com for the free item let's
get into the ama let's see what's going
on here i'm just going to join in i'm
not exactly sure how it's all going to
work
hello hello david pakman here
hi
uh well david i'm i'm doobie i'm the guy
that helps friends well i guess one of
the main people to help her on the
server thank you thank you for having me
very very much for agreeing to come
around today my pleasure
um is it okay if i pull you into another
channel for just a second i just want to
make sure we're on the same page about
you know everything
yeah i'm uh the only issue is like i'm
streaming right now so i don't know how
i can talk to you oh it is oh okay
yeah i'm just gonna pull you to another
channel for like uh a minute then we can
hop back and feel okay with that but to
be clear it's okay if my streaming
audience hears what we're gonna talk
about
yeah of course okay okay sounds good
yeah nothing crazy cool here we go
here we go
little behind the scenes
hello
hey so again thanks again for doing this
i really really really appreciate it
pleasure
somebody we've been trying to get on for
a very long time well i've personally
been trying to get on for a very long
time oh i'm glad to do it
um
and so the question you know very
standard are there any things you don't
want to talk about things you're like
not interested in talking about at all
um things you want us to avoid in terms
of not specifically i mean if i if i
just don't have anything substantive to
say i'll just say that's not really my
area or i don't feel strongly about that
or what but there's no like nothing's
off limits per se
okay
um in the next question is uh so
sometimes during these amas
we will unmute users and let them ask
their questions themselves if i trust
them not to be like a troll or say
something crazy
um are you okay with that or would you
rather i read the questions off oh i i i
mean i think it's much more compelling
to my audience certainly if i'm talking
to as many people as possible so i'm
totally up for that and you can use your
you know if you have whatever you know
if you want to kick them off you realize
people are getting problematic that's
totally fine but i'm glad to chat with
people
awesome okay we've done a ton of these
and and typically the the user base is
pretty well behaved okay yeah that's
good does it at any point where you know
you're just tired of talking to somebody
you have abilities to like mute or
disconnect people in the channel you
have like the perm to do that oh
beautiful if you ever just are not
interested in talking to somebody
anymore you can just meet them on your
end okay all right that sounds good and
just so my my so if if my audience wants
to join it's discord dot gg slash
politics and then they just go into the
david pakman voice chat right
yes sir and then they'll now they'll
have to verify or whatever
uh i'm actually going to reduce our like
moderation settings so that they can
join because typically uh we require
people to either have like a name uh i'm
sorry phone number attached
um and then if not that then they have
to be in a server for more than five
minutes to like uh type but i'm gonna
remove those and all they have to do is
have a verified email address on their
discord account that sounds great that
sounds great and i'm trying to think if
i had any other questions i guess not no
awesome okay well then i'll pull this
back down and get started beautiful
all right so everybody who's watching my
uh stream i'm sure you uh you heard the
the instructions there
um
it's all
it's all happening quite frankly this
should be very interesting this is a
major major discord server
i i appreciate you thinking that i mean
so far as i know we are like the uh
we're the largest uh political slash
debate server on discord wow how and is
it like 60 000 subscribers uh i think
we're like 62 000 right now wow well
let's try to get it to 62 0010. i think
i can help push it up to that
that'd be that'd be appreciated okay um
okay so i guess we'll get started um for
those of you who just got here i'm gonna
go over the you know how to how to uh
ask a question really quickly so we have
an ama questions text channel right
above this one if you want to ask a
question just type it out there one of
the mods will pin the question to that
channel and then i'll be going through
those questions if you want to ask a
question yourself i you don't want
meaning you don't want me to read it out
myself
just put vc at the start or the back of
your question so that i know you want to
ask yourself and if it's not like if
it's a good question i'll unmute you and
you can ask it yourself
um if you'd rather me just read the
question you know you've got like uh uh
you know stage fright or whatever that's
totally fine i just but please be uh
merciful to me and if you want me to
read out the question don't have it be
like three paragraphs
but uh those are the only rules um oh
and obviously
be respectful be civil no name calling
none of that um
i'll abide by that as well okay
okay i appreciate it thank you
um so david for for those
for those of people in the audience who
maybe haven't heard of your content
um can you maybe give them like a random
of what you do what you've been doing
all that good stuff you know uh and
where they can find you yeah sure uh so
i do uh the david pakman show it's a
nationally syndicated radio and
television show that also has a podcast
a youtube channel and a twitch
channel associated
on youtube we are approaching 1.5
million subscribers and very strongly so
if i would say
and the program airs on close to 200
radio and television stations we also
are on free speech tv for people who
have satellite television directv and
dish networks a left wing show i am not
a socialist i'm a social democrat i am
also not a member of the democratic
party and i say that only to
short-circuit questions about
why am i socialist this or that or
democrat or whatever you know i'm just
an independent left-leaning guy
all opinions on my show are my own and
that's basically the gist of it
awesome okay so i have a question please
uh before we get to the user question
um so i've been watching your content
for
i i think the first video viewers i saw
was your first interview with elizabeth
warren um
years ago that's a long time ago
yeah a very long time ago
um
and there's this seems like there's been
a lot of changes since then
um so like can you give us like um
i don't know like like a summary of what
that's been like you know being active
in in youtube
in this very like uh boisterous
political space with all this drama and
and keeping up with the news and i'm
sure you've spoken to many many people
over the years who are either getting
into politics or or maybe um
you know have have uh experience in in
politics and like what's what's that
been like just just interacting in the
space
and are there any like standout moments
well sadly it's gotten much much more
toxic i have to tell you um the level of
discourse has gone down to the gutter
and then i would even say sort of into
the bowels of the sewer system to use
the
some you know this sort of imagery
um
and particularly during the trump era
any even minor disagreements very
quickly become toxic and coarse and and
uh you know the anti-semitism comes out
and the personal attacks come out and
all of these things the bar
has become so low
for those who
i guess they believe they're
participating in political discourse but
but i don't know that they really are
and so what i've tried to do is like
really try to seek out
substantive conversations if we can
uh because i i find the toxicity and and
you know the pond scum
to be
very disappointing unfortunately it
doesn't bode well i feel like for the
future of of the country and the world
now a lot of people point to trump right
and everything leading up to that and
you know after his election
is like the the
source of that or maybe something that
pushed it over the tipping point would
you agree with that well i don't really
think that donald trump created
um
the the folks that i'm referring to i
don't think trump created xenophobia
racism or anything i think what happened
during the trump era is because trump
was so coarse in how he engaged with
other people
he allowed a lot of these folks who used
to be like oh i can't say a lot of this
stuff i already think it but i really
shouldn't say it or post it
they just became much more willing to
publicly engage in that way so i i just
think that donald trump was a catalyst
for
people being open to publicly being seen
engaging in this way but i don't think
trump created it
okay thank you uh so i'm gonna jump
right into the user questions because
there's a ton of them coming in sure uh
the first one is from bamhu the question
is
in regards to the ukraine border crisis
do you think putin should be charged as
a war criminal for his actions so that's
that's a great question it's really for
international lawyers and one of the
things i try to do is not
uh
if i if i'm if i if something is really
a matter of law for example
i really want to defer to the experts in
that so from from what i've seen there
are cases to be made that war crimes
were committed if the allegations about
bombing the kindergarten for example or
the orphanage are true
i've read compelling legal arguments
that there's a case for war crimes but
really
international law experts are the folks
that should address that more
substantively
okay
uh next question is from ocus mama the
question is who has influenced you in
your political ideals
oh there's it you know it's interesting
there's so many people that have but
it's mostly
historians and philosophers and you know
i i
am not really influenced by modern day
politicians to any great degree my
ideology is really based on a foundation
of reading history and politics and
economics etc so you know the the the
types of things i like to read that
really have been eye-opening for me are
for example the writings of will and
ariel durant or
bertrand russell or
um the stoics epictetus seneca etc um uh
economists and folks like adam smith and
you know etcetera so that's really the
basis so it's sort of boring because i
know a lot of people like well i'm i'm
kind of like a bernie tulsi gabbard guy
or you know who knows whatever
combination i don't really have anything
like that because i really don't
read modern political stuff if that
makes sense
okay great answer uh next question is
going to be from cube and this is our
first voice chat question cube whenever
you're ready please
hello
hello can you hear me yes i can
okay that's great
all right
mr pacman mr david pakman i was
wondering uh would you ever be friends
with somebody who was uh racist or
sexist or homophobic or transphobic or
anything under the sun of bigotry
so this is a really it's a very
interesting question um obviously
i
i can't possibly say the answer is a
flat no
because most people probably to some
degree harbor some of those prejudices
or have internalized some stereotypes
so i think
the way i would say it is
if
homophobia
or
racism or xenophobia are sort of like
guiding principles for an individual and
it's very present in my interactions
with them it would be really tough to
spend any serious amount of time with
that person
if on the other hand someone has sort of
like
some mild internalized misogynistic
beliefs that are not really
you know prevalent in my relationship
uh
i'm i'm i'm certain i'm friends with
people like that already you know what i
mean
yeah
okay
uh and then like just kind of another
mini question like what if your friend
said like like bro
that pacman i'm a nazi like i know we've
been friends for like 10 years but like
i just want to come out to you like i'm
i'm a nazi would you like try to change
his mind or would you just kind of like
disconnect yourselves from that depends
on the situation but i think that's
probably not someone i'm going to be
around too too much
gotcha all right thank you my pleasure
thank you
next questions from safety globalist
safety whenever you're ready
yeah sure uh i just wanted to say first
uh david pakman you are one of my
favorite youtubers and when i was very
young in the political scene you helped
keep me sane thank you i appreciate that
yeah i'm gonna my question go
here we go uh how do you feel about the
election of gabriel bork and where do
you think the political trajectory of
emerging countries like brazil and chile
are going in
i i don't know where they are uh
going but i am concerned about south
america
i would say basically as much as
the right word authoritarian slide in
eastern europe i think because of
the just inherent biases of how in the
u.s we just tend to pay more attention
to europe than latin america at a sort
of basic level um
we hear a lot more about europe but i'm
i'm very worried about what's going on
in latin america i mean the the chilean
election
um is a concern
uh obviously brazil has been a concern
for a long time
venezuela is a concern to me you know in
my birth country of argentina there's
just been a series of uh of
um horrible leaders uh from different
political persuasions so i have to tell
you i'm not super optimistic about latin
america right now
all right well thank you for answering
my question
my pleasure
okay next question is going to be from
[Music]
uh rengar for mod
do you think politics dreamers have to
be more responsible in how they show the
ukrainian russian conflict and this is
my kind of like addendum to that
question
um do you think they've been
irresponsible and
some of these people have been
irresponsible irresponsible the way
they've covered that
well there are certainly people who have
been
um wrong uh i mean you know there there
was a whole slate of people who were
saying
the intelligence about russian troops
massed at the ukrainian border is fake
um there there's not going to be an
invasion
if there is it's not going to be go
beyond the dunya and the luhansk i mean
they were all just wrong empirically
wrong there's no way to say that they
were right because it just literally the
opposite happened so
irresponsible is a different question
they were certainly completely wrong now
i think that
all politics streamers and content
creators
should take what they're doing
as seriously as as possible so whether
whether they need to do better
i would always say yes we want to make
an effort to do better but absent like
some specific examples i don't know what
more i can really say about it there
were many people that were very wrong
that's for sure
okay
uh next question is gonna be from zeus
um zeus actually someone who's
instrumental in making this ama happen
so i really really appreciate that zeus
see you soon everybody go for it
um yeah so
um a lot of people have been thinking
for quite some time that these oil
prices or inflation is going to be and
all these things are going to be the
same and i would say
let's say
all these things go down and it's less
of an issue do you think biden has a
really good chance of winning in 2024
against trump i want to hear your take
on this so
absent the inflation stuff and you know
we i don't want to get off on a tan i
want to really try to focus in on your
question specifically but
i've already three times now done my
rants about biden can do almost nothing
about gas prices and this is a global
issue and okay i'm not even going to do
that right now because it's not really
the question before any of this ukraine
russia stuff and the gas prices happened
uh i said
i if there's a rematch of 2020 and 2024
i don't think it's good for biden i said
that before any of this stuff because
biden has has gotten some things done
but the low approval the lack of recent
accomplishments etc i don't think it's
been good for him and i would be very
scared for biden if he has a rematch
against donald trump in 2024 assuming
trump is healthy which remains a real
kind of question mark um
biden's approval is actually going up
recently
most americans believe he's handling the
uh invasion of ukraine by russia well
and his state of the union seems to have
given him a bump as well but there's a
long time so i still maintain that i
don't like a trump biden rematch in 24
for biden i don't think that's good for
him if biden doesn't run and it's harris
versus trump i also don't think it's
good for kamala harris but i think it's
too early to tell whether the gas prices
is are really going to have an impact
because
it's almost three years away
awesome thank you my pleasure
hey uh next question is going to be from
uh me actually um so and this is i'm
actually piggybacking off to another
question but the question is um
i so on this in this community over the
years and also on twitch there there's
been a lot of um talk about platforming
and you know de-radicalizing people
and whether uh people should be allowed
to express uh certain opinions you know
um
and i'm kind of i don't think i've ever
looked into your take on that so like
what do you think about uh disallowing
um for example something that we've
we've struggled with on in this
community for a very long time
is allowing people to express like
holocaust now to have that debate on the
server right because this is something
that's very common like alright
communities that exist on the internet
some of those people come to the server
and they start saying these these silly
things
and
i'm sorry we've kind of struggled with
hate do we let these people say this
these silly things and then uh make sure
that people are there to argue against
them to show everybody there this is not
true or do we just shut down the
conversation entirely yep like what
would your position be on something like
that so this is this is a major issue i
think we in order to have as much
clarity as possible we should break the
question down into a couple different
things so first you're talking really
about content moderation on a private
server so
i
am a hundred percent
uh a defender
of you
as the server lead
being able to establish whatever terms
and conditions you want assuming that
there's no violation of the law or
whatever you know we're not saying we
don't allow black people on our server
or whatever basically short of that i'm
open to you deciding how you want to
moderate and saying we don't allow
holocaust denial or we don't allow overt
covet disinformation or whatever
i think that that's perfectly reasonable
on our subreddit and our discord
we don't allow covet disinformation we
don't allow
overt racist attacks we don't allow
holocaust denial etc so i i think that
those are individual decisions
similarly i have the same position for
twitter or youtube or whatever as long
as they are not
violating non-discrimination law by
saying we don't allow certain categories
of people
they have the absolute right to
establish terms of service and enforce
them now as a practical matter on my
show
my approach is responsible platforming
so i don't want to bring on
a neo-nazi
and allow them to spew their rhetoric
unchallenged
but that being said if i feel as though
it would be illuminating for my audience
and i'm equipped to rebut them
then i do interview extremists on my
program so that's a little bit you know
on my program is a little bit different
than like on social media platforms but
i i hope i'm kind of being clear about
these different categories